JLo and Shakira were spectacular last
night and we were everywhere to bring
you what no one else has crazy insight
into J Lo's entire Super Bowl Sunday
[Applause]
[Music]
JLo slid across the stage put her
hustlers stripper pole skills to good
use and proved that age is just a number
at the after-party the 50 year old
celebrated with a $6,000 cake complete
with sparklers and five layers each
layer representing one of her five
Versace halftime outfits
JLo first appeared wearing a biker look
with a pink satin skirt she quickly
tossed the skirt aside and was lowered
down in an all leather outfit JLo then
stripped down to an even sexier Versace
costume this skin-tight cher bodysuit
Jennifer added some color for costume
number four recreating the US and Puerto
Rican flags the piece was created with
40,000 red white and blue feathers all
individually sewn in and the final
fashionista moment a silver bedazzled
bodysuit so how did JLo prepare for her
big eight-minute performance first her
hair go big or go home
that's Jennifer's here expert brushing
out her extensions just minutes before
hitting the stage and those nails made
with Swarovski crystals we got more
behind-the-scenes details straight from
J Lo's inner circle Natasha oh my
daughter she's 15 she will give you all
the inside scoop of Jennifers
preparation for the Super Bowl I woke up
and my dad wasn't at home neither was
Jen they were actually at the gym
working out and then when they got home
Jen was rehearsing with her
choreographer wait a minute
I want the microphone cause you're too
good at this she's a natural what can I
say
a rod loved every second dancing on the
field and reuniting with Jennifer post
performance and the whole world is still
talking about JLo's eleven-year-old
daughter
Emmy who stole the show
my favorite part was like when the
little girls came out at em nice days
the coolest thing to watch my stepsister
saying I'm so proud of her every time I
see her and her voice is just angelic
[Music]